for like resurrections that just came
out which is freaking incredible I mean
what how much harder if you look back
when you were a lot you were you were
younger when the first Matrix came out
how I mean how many years I was 30. yeah
and now doing this how much harder for
you to tackle this immense project
again we had the support and
um and I was just so excited about doing
it
um there was a lot of mental preparation
that had to go into some of the action
um the actual physical action you know I
didn't do a heck of a lot
um
um so you know it was it was different
um but I was just so happy
to be a part of it because I just didn't
see that coming you know I think of
myself as pretty intuitive I have really
good like
you know senses and like that really
shocked me yeah and people were always
saying that they thought that it would
happen I was like no way like that is
never happening so I was really shocked
was there uh was there did you really
have three hours to uh of an audition
process or training for an audit for the
audition for the original Matrix
oh my gosh I had way more than that
um I think I did about six auditions for
that and one of the pieces of the
audition was three hours of fighting was
action
one part of it was that was you know
getting with the wire team the you know
the Hong Kong
um Team Masters
um and they would just sort of go
through the motions and you know
videotape the person and just you know
punch and kicking doing this doing that
and um I remember it always made me
laugh that the director said that when
they got my video
um they were like
you know every time they would kind of
cut back to the guy that I was fighting
he was patting himself up more and more
so I was actually hitting the guy and
like I didn't I didn't know about like
you know you know hit I mean I mean I
don't know how to do that so I was just
you know I could I could not walk the
next day I had an acting audition
uh for it it was pre-going to do like
the screen test with Keanu and I was
with the directors and I'm sitting in
the chair doing like one of the big
scenes of like waking him up I think at
the end of the movie and I did it one
time and the directors I think it was it
was actually my birthday my 30th
birthday and the directors asked me if I
could stand up
and I said I actually can't
you know and you think about it right
you're up for a big movie you do
anything
right like I actually couldn't like I I
was in so much pain
um in places in my body that I didn't
even know like that you had muscles
there you know it was it was intense